Một mỗi nơi mọi lúc quán ngày 1 mỗi nơi bày tại Th惠 Sánst đưa đánh giá là chận lũ tối tại nhất trong hàng thập kỳ
Chỉ trong vài giời lượng ngươi kỳ lực đồ xuống khu vực miệng Trung bằng Th惠 Sánst khiến các giống sông dân ca đột ngột và quân cho hàng loa trạy
nằm giọc nhiều sông của đa lúc hay chỉ tính dân tại hạt kỳ hơn tảm ư người từ nạc
Băng vông 2 bài trẻ em từ KEM MiStick, một cho miệng trạy hệ lượng nhất khu vực còn các hạt lần cận thi nhận hơn 2 mươi tịt mạc
Mui bán người mất tích, năng tổng số người thì mạng lên in nhất 1 trong lệ 1 người.
Dù lần Mỹ lấp tức đặt con hỏi với năng hực dự báo và hệ thống cảnh báo thiên tay,
chứ bối cảnh nhà trắng chưa đỏ từng các sản ứng sách dành cho các cơ quan khi tưởng.
Tuy nhiên, chính quyền tổng thống trong khẩn định đã thực hiện đầy đủ nghĩa vụ cảnh báo,
đồng thời khỏi đây là tham kịch không thể lượng chứa.
Chúng khi đó, công các tìm kiếm người mất tích vẫn còn tiếp tục.
Còn tích sách đăng cố gắng bước vào số đạn phục hồi sau cũng sốc chưa từng có trục dịp của khánh Mỹ.